yeah they're going to try to give it to
us actually to to show it
with sound they're going to pump up the
microphones from the playing menu
and uh we're going to listen carefully
if we can hear
the words shadow from behind us so even
if jan isn't
oh no that's definitely touched
okay
that he didn't jadoob that much let's
have it one more time because i was
talking sorry
he's not saying anything he did raise
his hand to say kind of as a gesture
that it's just an adjust but
it's not good chess etiquette i must say
it's really not i mean it's such a
strange move that you can kind of buy
that it would would be an adjusting move
because
magnus why would he ever move the night
there like moving the night makes no
sense
but
you just don't do it it's just
i don't know
you do while your opponents to the board
as you say shadoob or you do it after
you make your move you make the move and
then you clean this square or touch the
piece and then as long as you know
once you've made the move your opponent
knows that's the move you've made it's
no more touch piece move piece